how's it going bros - today we're going
to play with the iPad where there's a
lot of new awesome games are coming out
and what would grab we're gonna have so
much fun alright first game is called
superstars
it has Hugo in it wait go let's go back
look it's Hugo chief Hugo was my
childhood hero there used to be this I
don't think anyone cares man there yeah
but I'm gonna tell you anyway there used
to be this TV show for kids where you
could you could call in and you could
play the Hugo game oh my god and you
could play it while pressing your phone
keys and that would move Hugo for you
and it was always my dream to play it in
front of everyone and now my dream has
come true
so yes except except there's Ronaldo
there I don't I don't know what oh oh
this makes me wanna dance
okay superstars lights Wow let's begin
so we Ronaldo and we have to escape the
press on a skateboard not on a
skateboard nevermind okay I swipe I
double tap okay I can go back on my
skateboard yes
watch out well that was a close one
there was hell now my question is I
think you were all wondering the same
thing where is Hugo did Hugo get like
plastic surgery and become Ronaldo
cuz that's smart oh I collected an H
but the letters are faint memories of my
past so many questions in this game oh I
got to you Oh
get the AGG oh can we collect the
alphabet
I think know we got the G give me the oh
damn it
what happened want this song in my
funeral
no what the hell man wait here you we're
not really strung what is it this spring
you ready for this oh but I'm not gonna
question how it works I feel like I have
the potential to be MLG oh there it is
there's the last one come on come on
come on I got the helo here you go you
go where are you here going look wow did
i unlock the Hyuga hey you go heal
cocoon go here go slower oh my god here
we go what that why why a persistent is
this paparazzi if he follows me after
that you know what give me another yeah
boy it's your boy to go on oh here go
kun damn look yo
look what yeah my holy crap yeah five
and punch baby okay I'm slowly getting
addicted to this I don't think this is a
healthy yeah that was a pretty cool game
you can check it out in description
download if you want online next gate
this game is called try harder
this is try harder oh my god [ __ ] sake
tap to make small down what do they tell
me after I die oh shut up oh is this you
cannot win you can only try harder tell
me how to live my life woman I don't
understand this game
I don't understand it tell you keeps
telling me to try harder but I feel like
society already puts enough on you I
shouldn't have to keep trying harder
every day next game yeah oh you feel it
okay dance man impress tap anywhere to
move oh game oh what's up oh yeah look
at these lumps [ __ ] oh look at these
lumps look at these lumps oh this is how
I danced at the club like a point spy oh
oh oh I get it I love everyone away
that's smaller than me straight is just
like bullying am I getting lumpier from
lumping people that's all so just like
we like
and this game has great message luf away
[ __ ] muffle way
oh yeah that's bad slump all day and
lump all night party number two okay
well you know what I get it it's okay I
get it I get it I don't have to play
more
I don't know what this game is it looks
pretty amazing yeah oh okay
it's and I explode
that was the greatest two seconds of
gameplay I've ever had in my laugh
why am i cray this game is so beautiful
I got a burger shoe haha oh yes can't
stop won't stop so I save the burgers so
I can throw them up on people [ __ ]
love the music actually hahaha
[ __ ] you frog [ __ ] [ __ ] you Ron walk oh
look something oh man
okay look how many levels it has Jesus
Christ what is that a tee it's that a
t-rex
[ __ ] sake what am I supposed to do there
I'm out of burgers this game has no no
respect for life well you know what I
think that's as much fun as we'll ever
gonna get out of that game
of course finally I want to check out
tadpole jump because it's made by other
minds which are the fellows that are
working on the PewDiePie game right now
I played it a little bit it's really
cool so you basically are this I don't
know what what we are we're Kauai is
[ __ ] that's all that we are man I can't
wait to be able to play in a pewdiepie
game such a gorgeous pixel art - alright
oh god what is happening get the magnet
now paratus okay I don't how does this
even work how fast do I need to be damn
damn girl sonic fist Sinek hmm oh god
yah I was taking it so slow go go little
tadpole friend nah
Oh God I got electrified oh man that
made me sweat that was a workout I wish
you ran like this in real life - with
your tongue that would just be amazing
then I would truly be happy oh god no no
no yes
hi skewer baby Wow know when your tongue
is not enough
alright alright alright it looks like
we're out of time Bruce but boy oh boy
do we have a lot of fun today I had a
lot of fun I don't know about you I
can't really see what you're doing you
may have you may had a good snack you
may have had got a haircut you may have
watched his on a roller coaster then you
definitely had a lot of fun but in the
end we did it together that's all that
matters
so became way deeper than I thought
alright thank you for watching leave
like if you want and I'll see you in the
next one is always gross scary awesome
run Jesus run and you start off as
little pixel fate of Jesus here and we
can run at how do we play let me try
this one
there you go scourge eaters alright and
Jesus go now